♫ Musique ♫
Yeah !
Je prends de la valeur avec l'âge comme des cartes Yu-Gi-Oh.
Mon flow est en feu, j'suis plus chaud qu'un cubilot
Monte le son dans le casque, écoute nos histoires.
Les MC pètent un câble ... épissoir.
Prends tes places, viens voir le spectacle
Tu vas kiffer jusqu'à la fin quitte à mourir d'une épectase.
Tu dis que t'es bon mais j'ai un petit doute,
T'es tellement à l'ancienne toi tu fumes pas la chicha tu fumes le chibouque.
Il n'est pas trop tard pour faire péter le quota, j'suis calme grand et froid, comme une merzlota.
On reste les mêmes et ça jusqu'à la fin, j'suis pote avec Le Petit Robert et le grand Alain.
🔥 Quand on débarque, ouvre le dico.
On fait du rap, avec n'importe quel mot. 🔥
🔥 Tu prends ta claque, en deux minutes chrono. 🔥
🔥 C'est qui ?
Squeezie, Oli, Bigflo ! 🔥
🔥 Quand on débarque, ouvre le dico.
On fait du rap, avec n'importe quel mot. 🔥
🔥 Tu prends ta claque, en deux minutes chrono. 🔥
🔥 C'est qui ?
Squeezie, Oli, Bigflo ! 🔥
J'suis plutôt calme, je ne fais pas de drames.
Posé chez oim, j'me fais une omelette au cryptogame.
Rapper c'est ma mission, mais fais attention.
J'évite les «nique ta sœur», j'préfère les nictations.
J'suis devenu à la mode, comme le quinoa.
Discret, efficace comme un shinobi.
Je balance mes shurikens tout droit de Konoha.
Et dans le slip, j'ai un très très gros conoïde.
Tu veux t'attaquer à moi pose toi et réfléchis mon pote.
Ou sur ton corps apparaîtront des tas de pétéchies.
Sois pas débile, dans mon équipe, tu iras vite, y'a que des bons.
Mes punchlines te font l'effet d'un coup dans l'épiploon.
C'est un appel au risque, à la pelle j'vends des disques.
J'vole au dessus du game comme un pétauriste.
Avec Squeezie, on s'approche un peu plus du soleil.
Protégés par la bénédiction d'Alain Rey.
🔥 Quand on débarque, ouvre le dico.
On fait du rap, avec n'importe quel mot. 🔥
🔥 Tu prends ta claque, en deux minutes chrono. 🔥
🔥 C'est qui ?
Squeezie, Oli, Bigflo ! 🔥
🔥 Quand on débarque, ouvre le dico.
On fait du rap, avec n'importe quel mot. 🔥
🔥 Tu prends ta claque, en deux minutes chrono. 🔥
🔥 C'est qui ?
Squeezie, Oli, Bigflo ! 🔥
Aujourd'hui j'sors de l'ombre, pour vous piquer, trombidion.
T'es l'chihuahua, j'suis l'beau Shiba Inu, t'es bidon.
J'suis aussi crédible qu'un moine sans cuculle, j'm'en bats les couilles.
Tes sons c'est que des catachrèses, tu t'touches la nouille.
Tu parles comme un mec qui force sur la bouteille.
Inutile de faire de la logopédie, achète pas d'Encyclopédie.
Tu t'appelles pas Alain Rey
🔥Tu peux pas tester le King 🔥
J'veux pas mourir d'inanition, d'inanition.
Mais j'veux chiller, chiller avec mes kheys.
J'aime pas trop les hipsters, j'préfère ceux qui me disent,
🔥 Oh mon khey, t'es l'sang, t'es l'sang🔥
Ca c'est peut-être pas du freestyle, mais j'crois que ça fera le job. (echo)
♫ Musique ♫
🔥 Quand on débarque, ouvre le dico.
On fait du rap, avec n'importe quel mot. 🔥
🔥 Tu prends ta claque, en deux minutes chrono. 🔥
🔥 C'est qui ?
Squeezie, Oli, Bigflo ! 🔥
🔥 Quand on débarque, ouvre le dico.
On fait du rap, avec n'importe quel mot. 🔥
🔥 Tu prends ta claque, en deux minutes chrono. 🔥
🔥 C'est qui ?
Squeezie, Oli, Bigflo ! 🔥
♫ On est les boss, on dirige les mots comme Alain Rey
On est les boss, on dirige les mots comme Alain Rey ♫
Sous-titrage par Jules Morel
Un grand bravo à Squeezie, Oli, Bigflo pour ce clip !
Passez une bonne journée !